hip-hop is encompassing and breaks
through style branding information
poetry melody storyline all at one time
and the reason why I completely crushed
the RMV genre and why I became the new
rock and roll and reason why me and
jay-z
sat in front of a you know American flag
is because I was looking at Bruce
Springsteen covers and saying okay we're
America makes the best music from
traveling around the world like okay it
Italy makes the best suits and this
makes the Vespa blah but America brings
the the greatest pop stars and the
greatest music that's why me and jay-z
sat in front of it and what I want to
point out with the Samsung deal is there
would have been no Beats deal without
the Samsung deal because it showed now
that Steve has passed even though Steve
might have seen it it showed a number
one company the importance of connecting
with culture and I know you might have
heard about this thing where I was on
stage like calling Tim Cook out and
saying why do you have you know these
guys performing at South by Southwest
and you don't want to pay him and you
just want to give us like extra space on
the iTunes page and stuff you know but
meanwhile Samsung realized the whole
point of what we're saying is that no
you have to go and pay these guys that's
right culture and creativity is worth
something and the best thing about the
fall of blackberry and the rise of Apple
is the win for creativity and companies
that are based off the idea and that
just based off of the amount of product
that they can put out you know hip-hop
has grown so exponentially it's the
first genre in the music industry that
bridged lifestyle and selling product
Run DMC saying hold up your Adidas
sneakers wear your track suits will.i.am
in 2009 in boom boom pow talking about
Beats headphones was it the first john
room usik that said you like my style
I'm gonna sell it to you yeah because
black people are allowed to wear like
big chains and name what they have on
and say out loud with stuff costs
because you know
I wasn't Mick Jagger selling these
skinny pants 30 years ago it just it
just was uncool at that time it'll go
through waves and stuff will go through
waves of civilization will not not be as
cool anymore like on my last album you
know I completely took the to be known
as the really baton down in this outlet
and how the name drop all these you know
people by association like I name drop
spike jonze earlier they like make
myself look cooler like that's my friend
you know it's all it's like by
association thing that people you know
gain their own confidence and found that
you know how the time we just spend it
on their family and less time to just
you know spend in stores one thing I
wanted to point out with Jimmy Iovine
and dr. Dre it's not they are geniuses
both of them were cultural geniuses what
they had done for so many years and they
just they they connected with the right
company by the way it's all about the
legacy of Steve what kind of gut or iron
conviction do you have to have to be one
of those breakthrough innovators when
you did was it six months ago bound to
Kanye those first few days people said
what is this is he making fun of me and
a week later sociology professors we're
teaching courses about this video saying
it's genius
what kind of gut do you need to have
just say I'm gonna stick this out I know
this is the way we're going
I don't like write self-help books or
anything like that this is
you just you have to be able to take the
take the lashes of people down
understanding you know two years of
people not understanding interracial
relationship like that two years of
people don't understanding the idea of
the art world meets the pop world you
have to be able to take the lashes and
be able to swim and backlash and a lot
of times you know I think that I get a
bad rap for saying I could do this I
could do this but what it's like what we
are like are the creatives with teeth so
we have the gut feeling and we know that
the idea is more important than our
personal well-being that's the reason
why a lot of times I'll say things that
are not for my personal well-being which
i think is a for people to create for
their personal well-being is a very
selfish way to create and you're
creating to make your life better as
opposed to creating to make everybody's
life better so you know the only thing I
think I could be an inspiration to
graders is the fact that I get bashed so
much but create so much so it's like
just know if you really want to be a
boxer you're gonna get your face beat in
you know constantly but then you might
end up being Mayweather ollie
you know at the end of it